das ist tatsächlich ein ziemlicher
durchbruch es ist eine super solarzelle
die ein deutsches forschungsteam jetzt
entwickelt hat es handelt sich um eine
sogenannte tandem solarzelle
sie schaffte es mehr als 29 prozent des
sonnenlichts in strom umzuwandeln
durch die kombination verschiedener
materialien entsteht also eine
weltrekord technik die den solarstrom
deutlich günstiger machen könnte ist das
der durchbruch der energiewende kriegst
du das als lucia geht es dreimal pro
woche spannende science videos abonniert
den kanal und aktiviert die glocke nur
so verpasst ihr nichts los geht
[Musik]
willkommen und vielen dank für diesen
hammer themenvorschlag den uns alexander
über unsere klicks um science in future
talibangruppe geschickt hat aufstellung
bekommt er die videos früher und ihr
könnt mit diskutieren und themen
vorschlagen her unter mir geht es super
gramm also draufklicken forschungsteams
weltweit die sich mit solarzellen
beschäftigen haben vor allem ein ziel
sie wollen die solarzellen nicht nur
günstiger machen sondern vor allem die
effizienz der zellen steigern bisher
schaffen die zellen auf hausdächern so
um die 20
konkret bedeutet das aus 100 ein
fallender strahlungsenergie kommen etwa
20 prozent als strom heraus und
solarzellen aus silizium werden immer
günstiger und effizienter doch es gibt
eine herausforderung auch diese
ausgangsstoff kann nur einen gewissen
wirkungsgrad bieten
dieser liegt derzeit etwa bei bis zu 26
7 prozent theoretisch doch hier ist
ebenso langsam schluss wie fachleute
weltweit feststellen müssen zudem
handelt es sich dabei um die besten und
somit auch sehr teuren solarzellen auf
siliziumbasis doch eine neu entwickelte
tandem zelle ist jetzt in der lage sogar
29,15 prozent des eingestrahlten lichts
in elektrische energie umzuwandeln dabei
handelt es sich um eine solarzelle die
aus dem halbleiter silizium peroxid
besteht die kombination dieser beiden
materialien sorgt somit für einen neuen
rekord in diesem bereich mit dieser
rekord solarzelle ist die 30% effizienz
marke in greifbare nähe gerückt und klar
ist weiter und neuentwicklung von
solarzellen begünstigen die energiewende
das ziel hierbei so viel sauberer strom
wie möglich zu akzeptablen kosten zu
erzeugen klar ist die neu entwickelte
tanz
solarzellen der deutschen fachleute vom
helmholtz-zentrum berlin hzb könnte
dafür sorgen dass der preis für
solarstrom deutlich sehen doch wie wurde
die entwicklung dieser pandemie
solarzelle möglich bereits seit längerer
zeit konzentrieren sich fachleute in
diesem bereich darauf materialien zu
kombinieren das motto wenn man zwei gute
dinge kombiniert kommt noch etwas
besseres heraus und so haben die
berliner forschende silizium solarzellen
mit sogenannten pair of speed
solarzellen kombiniert beide sind
bereits für sich alleine ziemlich
effizient doch erst die kombination
dieser beiden halbleitermaterialien
führt zu dem rekordwert von 29,15
prozent fachleute in diesem bereich
haben schon vor längerer zeit die so
genannten perrons kita im visier
diese werden manchmal sogar als die
hoffnungsträger schlechthin der solar
branche bezeichnet dabei handelt es sich
um äußerst effiziente direkter
halbleiter die auslösung gewonnen werden
eine peroxid schicht kann bis zu 100 mal
dünner sein als eine siliziumschicht und
dennoch genauso viel licht absorbiert
dabei handelt es sich um sehr leichte
und ultradünne materialien die sich
somit vor allem auch für gekrümmte
flächen anbieten beispielsweise als
faltbare solarzellen etwa auf gebäude
fassaden oder auf autos man könnte quasi
alles damit pflastern nach dem motto
mehr ist mehr und das könnte dann
tatsächlich unglaubliche
skalierungseffekte haben wenn wir
plötzlich alle elektronik mit rucksäcken
jackentaschen und so weiter laden würden
bräuchten diese geräte schon mal keinen
strom mehr aus kraftwerken und es gibt
ein weiteres spannendes einsatzgebiet
das denkbar wäre nämlich solarzellen im
weltall hergestellt werden perus kita
aus komponenten die preiswert und leicht
verfügbar sind wie beispielsweise metall
salze das ist einer der großen vorteile
ihre fertigung ist besonders einfach in
solarzellen wurden sie zum ersten mal
vor rund zehn jahren eingesetzt schon
von beginn an überzeugt waren fachleute
von ihrem wirkungsgrad und eben nicht
überrascht innerhalb weniger jahre
konnte dieser auf 25,5 prozent gepusht
werden im vergleich dazu der silizium
wirkungsgrad liegt bei maximal 26 7
prozent und das eben erst nach
jahrzehntelanger verbesserung der
nachteil der bürosuite solarzellen sind
bislang auch sehr sensibel und reagieren
an ihren grenzflächen was ihre
leitfähigkeit
einschränkt so wurde vor allem an der
stabilität der perrons kita gearbeitet
denn ihre organischen bestandteile
reagieren empfindlich auf hitze und
feuchtigkeit anfällige komponenten
wurden in den vergangenen jahren also
ersetzt und mehr an organische
komponenten eingebracht dennoch im
vergleich dazu sind silizium solarzellen
zum heutigen zeitpunkt sehr viel länger
nutzbar
während silizium insbesondere die roten
anteile des sonnenlichts in strom
umwandelt nutzen barofsky verbindung vor
allem die blauen anteile des spektrums
also die sichtbaren anteile des
sonnenlichts eine tandem solarzellen aus
silizium per ski kann also das
sonnenspektrum sehr effizient nutzen und
schafft dadurch deutlich höhere
wirkungsgrade als jede einzelne zelle
für sich genommen an dieser kombination
tüfteln wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftler bereits seit einiger
zeit doch das große problem die perrons
kiesschicht auf dem silizium zeigt sich
unter bestrahlung er instabil so kommt
es zu qualitätseinbußen
doch auch diese herausforderung haben
die fachleute aus berlin gemeisterten
haben es so geschafft den bisherigen
weltrekord bei tandem solarzellen aus
prieros skeet und silizium von 28
prozent übertroffen
ihr wirkungsgrad liegt eben bei 29,15
prozent und das ist ein neuer weltrekord
doch nicht nur der wirkungsgrad ist
super dazu heißt es auf der webseite des
forschungsteams darüber hinaus zeichnet
sich die neue box trieb silizium kann
der zelle durch eine stabilität von mehr
als 300 stunden unter kontinuierlicher
belastung an luft aus und zwar ohne
durch eine verkapselung geschützt werden
die instabilität des perrons keat unter
bestrahlung umging das forschungsteam
mit hilfe eines zitat perfekten bettes
wie der beteiligten wissenschaftler am
rand einer jury erklärt die rede ist von
einer zwischenschicht aus organischen
molekülen diese ordnen sich
selbstständig zu einer sogenannten mono
lage as a m
dies wurde dann von den fachleuten auf
der elektrode aufgebracht und sorgt
dafür dass die von der sonne erzeugten
ladungsträger schneller abschließen und
nicht verloren gehen dazu am ramallah
jury wir haben sozusagen zuerst das
perfekte bett eingerichtet auf das sich
die peroxid schicht legt diese
hauchdünne schicht bezeichnen die
fachleute als ein zitat methyl
substituierte carbazol
anlage die unterschiedlichen prozesse
die an den grenzflächen zwischen der
elektrode dem perron skeet und sm
abliefen nahm die wissenschaftlerinnen
und wissenschaftler aus berlin dann
genauer ins visier dazu alle jury wir
haben insbesondere den fünfakter
optimiert der dadurch beeinflusst wird
wie viele ladungsträger auf dem weg aus
der peer austrieb unter zelle verloren
gehen so wurde klar dass die shm schicht
den abtransport unterstützt und sich die
perrons kiesschicht somit stabiler zeigt
dadurch wird nach angaben des
forschungsteams also der hohe
wirkungsgrad von 29 15 prozent
ermöglicht und die 300 stunden betrieb
ohne eine schützende verkapselung das
klingt erst mal wenig ist aber im
vergleich mit anderen experimenten
tatsächlich eine extrem gute zeit für
den einsatz in der solarindustrie
dagegen reicht das noch lange nicht hier
gilt das versprechen dass die module
auch nach 25 jahren noch etwa 80 prozent
der anfänglichen leistung erbringen
können und es kommen noch weitere
herausforderungen auf die fachleute zu
um die solarzellen für den massenmarkt
einsatzbereit zu machen dazu alle jury
da ist zum einen die wissenschaftliche
aufgabe zu verstehen warum die
grenzfläche so empfindlich ist und wie
man das problem dauerhaft löst zudem
müsste auch noch an der technologie
gearbeitet werden durch die perrons
titel großflächig abgeschieden werden
löcher oder andere fehler müssen dabei
im besten fall vermieden werden die neu
entwickelte tandem zelle ist gerade
einmal einen quadratzentimeter groß die
berliner wissenschaftlerin
wissenschaftler gehen davon aus dass
noch gute zehn bis 15 jahre forschung
notwendig sind sie sehen die
realistische grenze für den wirkungsgrad
dieser tandem zellen aus gips keaton und
silizium bei rund 35 prozent
zunächst wird das forschungsteam die
effizienz über die 30er marke pimpen und
auch dafür gibt es nach angaben der
fachleute selbst schon mögliche
lösungsvorschläge auf jeden fall ein
meilenstein und ehrgeizige ziele aber es
ist wahnsinnig wichtig hier fortschritte
zu erzielen
denn die versorgung ausschließlich mit
regenerativen energien ist nicht nur
kein echsen oder teufelswerk sondern
dringend nötig damit uns der klimawandel
hier in deutschland nicht langsam das
wasser ab dreht denn das liegt in nicht
allzu ferner zukunft klimawandel schlägt
zu im sommer könnte deutschland
austrocknen anklicken anschauen und aber
ich freue mich auf euch als treue
abonnieren bis dann bleibt dran